bene tutti ragazzi nuovo video siamo su
rocket league con lauri bis che
finalmente ci avete chiesto stato
lavorazione in 2000 ci siamo per me
allora abbiamo fatto già un paio di
partite giusto per scaldarci per
conoscerci e per insegnarmi come si
accendono solo perché adesso meno ha
spiegato qui dovremmo riuscire a giocare
delle partite recenti allora comunque
sia il discorso è che effettivamente in
questa e queste quella cosa che ha
spiegato sempre ragazzi quando io gioco
a diamante 3 noto è questa la cosa che
non farà mai mancare a chi ci sono un
sacco di champion de rancati ecco quelle
di siamo tutti più forti a prescindere
quindi calvino è più fosco accaduto
spacchiamo tutto è più quando vai
andarci piano turbo ma credo nel cuore
la mia macchina effetto per amici
arrivati aiuto nel cuore della tua
macchina e niente con me nella mia
macchina che non o turno la prova a
tirare di nuovo portale ribasso però in
qualche modo mi l'appello lanciato tempo
dove rubò il playout non male romano
amore inizio però un rigo versus lauri
di mamma mia mamma mia come si intendono
questi ragazzi utilissima perché
passaggio che i ragazzi non mi vedrete
mai più fare una roba del genere come
sentiamo parte adesso quando io so per
me importa qui ap dissocio sto
scherzando o via non ora io sono per
l'intero turno stavolta ti prego ciò che
abbiamo già perso ma dai topi oggi
rischioso mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia
mamma mia ma che i ragazzi sono ma
incredibile è sempre molto utile
spettate lo dico dopo che visto dove 700
900 il mio cervello va e non è bastato
ebbene basta tenere per sempre
duecento per cento del cervello nostra
allo stato cgc gvb bravi bravi surbo lei
king gang allora sorvoliamo limiti devo
dire allora posso così azione limone
angolino che bravo perfetto sfondo to
buy domani lo facevano per busto
perché se devo fare usalo tu che eri
posto in mani migliori e opera passati
tutti i mari di togliermi dalle palle
vai sfondo risponde disco perfetto tiro
in porta però non è da te importa 6
notti di giurie spaghetti o sono balzate
album city ha avuto paura ma no dai non
ha scavalcato di niente però demoliscono
non lo devo vivere
puoi tirare così e vinciamo questa
partita dai allora dillo subito
vogliamo vincere la pellicola sarà vero
scrive e basta ha detto prima di votare
sì sì sì sì
non so proprio fare limoura non solo
tirare e sperare che la palla va di
importa però fare coppa in modo guarda
perché taruta gaeta a ruvo mi sono
cagato addosso
no no no volevo però non ho turbo per
andare sui demolisce la madre di un
altro show yes prepara ora lavorata per
in eyes il ragazzo che tenta la debole
tira ma c'è il papi che dice sì da
interventi rapidi fa vi dice che può
insegnare perché fate una bella volta no
quindi quando l'avversario fa una bella
cosa tu non riesci segnare questo va
dicendo che la sportività si chiama
anche giampiero taglia questa voragine
bloccarlo un pò di heine non possiamo
fare del vostro vincere si è creato un
hype perché sono il video non ha senso
se no diciamo solo perché sul rendono è
distrutto soprattutto life guasta nel
falli che dà titolo che stanno facendo
questo tipo di struttura sfondo lo
tocchi ciao bello è palo no no e allora
niente mi dissocio ragazzi che devo fare
visto cdp non è vero mai nel mondo ma
che libertà ma che vai male ma che
questo non voleva farlo
ragazzi questa sta vedendo cioè non lo
so è una bella parola bellissimo lei che
mi sento di vetro in cui è fatto se non
lo salta bravissimo bravissimo e non ci
arrivo tanto no
checchino troppo avanti sono un bad
posizionatore serve un po di cose ma si
dice serve un po di gol da trenta
secondi stanno mangiando tutti i tour vi
stanno mangiando perché o mio dio con
tutti grande aiuto aiuto bravissimo
hayama demolito e c'è un problema di c
as 13 13 miglior busti non c'è il gusto
tutto tuo si no essere diretto in porta
facciamo ce la faccio no 5 secondi ti
prego segnava 12 13 33 dc non ho turbo 1
tirato atletico della guerra ha vinto
per il nome scusami se ti dicono in
concordo come pazze allora so niente so
se vuoi se vuoi lo metto nel tag e mi
dissocio open source e la ferrata
youtube troppo basse
non è vero mai della madonna che
passaggi di genova era questo quello che
i tempi
mamma mia mi sono staccata ma che
aspettava da mesi nessuno ha mai fatto
sono emozionato
guardiamo per qualche tempo ben è stato
preso il palo ma era tutto per
spaventare la polemica perché stavo
sotto quell'attimo di sospensione
dell'incredibile se si si segua grand
champion è solo perché partiamo subito
con un 1 a 0 tattico con questi ragazzi
del messico dell'alghero al nome più
bello di rocketeer avevo mai visto per
un larga non è anche a ma quando viene
stimato a un mio diario corribile
aiutavi sisti ci sono ma abbiamo
scavalcato 3 col noto però ci vuole
infatti le quali cazzo a lo fai tu apre
due pack si è l'avevo fatto ma niente
pincio
avevo capitolo facile uniti mi sono
fermato ok ok ora pinto
non è vero nei contrasti passa perfetto
di nuovo 9 ci crede e rose m non volevo
proprio farlo passare un bravissimo
questo è pericoloso pericoloso
pericoloso il lag che la mette in mezzo
si chiude va bene c'è broccatello sì sì
sì sì sì aspetto cioè sì sì no no va
bene va bene prenotare in rete o certo
che però si è confuso io così confusa
dato che è un po che monta un pochino
ok beh il nome c'era dopo comunque
sempre su rack nell'immagine un po demo
sul rex si esce anche un tipo l'on
però vi secolo dei mail sul re che tipo
lotta si è rotta roma
eppure io immagino così aspetta che la
controllo
allora l'ho mai visto questo controllo
ecco segnato perché io così bene non lo
farò mai più
questo è un bel controllo palla al piede
ok
mamma mia come lo pincha tacche cussì
riguarda questo video dice mamma mia ma
chi gliel'ha insegnato sto ragazzo che
vuole imparare a mamma mia che bel goal
complimenti da ho ribaltato ma da bianca
donna non è possibile allora ragazzi
soprattutto schiacciare il freno tirato
il freno a mano dio disconnesso il
computer che stavo tirando però è stata
una bell'azione corsa per mettermi
creativa onesta e anche abbandono della
personaggi di forza è che dobbiamo fare
va bene ragazzi direi che per oggi va
bene così è stato emozionante se fosse
lee masters anno c'era un fosse voluto
fatemi sapere se ero né da altri col
maestro laurentiis che insomma c'è
intesa se posso dire ragazzi a un
prossimo video di scheda che mi piace
come sempre ma ci si stanca scagionati
beh ragazzi
[Musica]